do you find that you have like
it's hard to like
when stories start coming out to just
not top like we have so many [ __ ]
crazy stories like when you start
digging into the wild
boys there's actually a few of the
greatest photos ever taken yeah
you're in i think three of them
the greatest photo ever taken
and deleted i mean that was the greatest
photo ever taken by the way that was so
much funnier than the the front flip
over right i would tell this story like
like we're in indonesia
and i was i was heartbroken because i
had i had lost
what was at that time the love of my
life
and uh and we were super sympathetic
yeah i was i was i was heartbroken
and and somehow i just ended up drunk
and i was just like nah you know i'm
trying to get over it and here i meet
this
this lady of the night at the at this
bar in indonesia
and and and and i bring her back to my
hotel room and here i am and i'm i'm
just having sex with this this is your
first time with a hooker correct
my first time with the hooker was after
gumball rally oh okay so second second
time with ogre uh
in my head when i tell the story it's
your first time with the hookers
my first time with a hooker in indonesia
and uh and and i'm sure i'm having you
know sex with this hooker and all of a
sudden
let me tell this let me take over
because like
so stevo like we're in this little
shitty ho we're on some island i don't
remember where borneo
and
like shitty little hotel and we know
what stevo's up to and we're all [ __ ]
wasted so it's me pontius dimitri
uh
i don't think knoxville climbed in there
um
cordell
uh
we're all
gathered around and we
sneak into your room you're having sex
in a pitch black room you pitch black
room i had an idea and we [ __ ]
stealthily pick your lock or just i
don't think the room was like we open
the door and we crawl in on this pitch
black floor while you're just [ __ ]
away on the bed
and then
we're all in the room
and then demetri stands up and hits a
flash photo i thought the photo was
taken from outside no right in the room
right last photo and we're all thumbs up
and you're [ __ ] on the bed with your
eyes glowing like lividly mad
and uh
and we take the flash goes off and then
like it like and we run out both out of
this room and you are [ __ ] livid
and we all run and try to hide and you
come tearing in like [ __ ] right so i
can do this damage control and i have to
promise you that i'll delete the photo
and then you proceed to go back to your
room and tear it apart please live for a
living oh dude yeah i destroyed this one
full molly crew in the room retaliation
for that i mean i was just acting out i
was drunk i was like man like i i was i
was
philosophically trying to get over this
this love of my life we were also coming
off of like a really hard india like a
gnarly this was a very gnarly 29 street
shooting days yeah gnarly shooting
schedules the day i got home i got
arrested on an airplane
right so what we're smoking chain
smoking oh that was the yeah yeah dude i
got to make a video for that just just
and then and then and that was the photo
and so we then we and then we we we go
and we are just dying laughing over this
photo i mean this photo is
the flash went off perfectly you're mid
pump but you and are looking looking at
us but with red eyes like so it looks
demonic
and then pontius is standing up like
just thumbs-upping like uh it is the
funniest [ __ ] picture in
and like i go and they like then i have
to go like then i'd go break the new we
looked at the picture then you came in
furious i had a promise we'll delete the
picture
and then i go to dimitri and he's like
jeff don't make me delete this picture
steve was going to want this picture i'm
like no man
he made me promise that i delete the
picture and he's like
i do want it
he was absolutely right like and he's
like he's right don't make me delete
this picture you're going to regret it
and i'm like no you have to delete it
i mean no i watched him delete it he
didn't have time what's that
and you know how much is the
we have the story we have the story but
that photo was so [ __ ] good
you would have loved that picture matt
like yeah i mean if we were gonna say
top three gnarliest things that happened
on the road man it's a tough it's a big
bag to pull out oh god well but uh i
mean that we can talk about yeah yeah
dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]